few people in the entertainment industry
of the 90s had more power than Tim Allen
in addition to a thriving career in
stand-up comedy and roles and movies
like the Santa Claus Galaxy Quest and
Toy Story he sat on ABC's Home
Improvement one of the most watched TV
shows of the decade based on a major
element of his comedy act but man was
still essentially ill-equipped cavemen
had evolved early enough to enjoy power
tools Allen played Tim the tool man
Taylor Tim was a bumbling husband and
father and host of tool time a
michigan-based home improvement show
which invariably ended up with him
breaking something here's a look behind
the scenes of ABC's 8th season smash a
tale of two Jill's patricia richardson
wasn't the first actress to play the
role of Tim Taylor's long-suffering wife
Jill actress Frances Fisher originally
landed the role and performed it for the
pilot taping more the inaugural episode
was successful enough to get the show on
ABC scheduled test audiences didn't like
Fisher in the role so if little time to
spare before production started the show
runners were plays Fisher with
Richardson even though it wasn't ideal
timing I just given birth to yeah two
babies and I really was supposed to do
another show for ABC and and now
supposed to happened nine months later
so I was gonna have all this time to
lose weight and and go be with my babies
the other show was cancelled though so
they offered a double salary to play as
jail Richardson Warren produces that
there might be a set delay as a result
of a new motherhood I said look I'm
nursing twins you have to wait for me
for 40 minutes while I'm doing that and
and they said oh well yeah we'll do
anything and so the new mum started
raising her on-screen kids alongside her
real-life babies you can almost call him
al you probably know character actor
Stephen Tobolowsky from just about
everything from Groundhog Day to Silicon
Valley to the Goldbergs but the actor
could have had a long lasting regular
gig or home improvement if he wanted it
Topol offski originally won the role of
our Borland Tim Taylor's long-suffering
extra competent tool time assistant he
walked away however when they couldn't
assure him of a proper start date and
still wanted an exclusive contract toby
Loski told split cider
i couldn't do any other work any other
shows which is normal on a regular show
but my wife was pregnant we had a
becoming I had auditions for a couple of
movies and was waiting on them and they
said I couldn't do movies rather than
risk of being broke for months Tobel of
ski parted ways of home improvements and
the part of being the butt of every joke
went to Richard Karn instead Ashley Judd
needs no improvement Pamela Anderson's
high profile career really started when
she played Lisa the tool girl on tool
time
the show-within-a-show on home
improvement but award-winning star and
activist Ashley Judd also tried out for
the part when she auditioned for the
show creator Matt Williams thought she
was so talented even too talented for
the somewhat thankless iCandy role of
Lisa Williams called Judds agent and
said that while she didn't get the part
he was going to create a role just for
her as Tim Taylor's sister but that
alpha was declined and she went on to
star in NBC's drama sisters instead
Chappelle's first show home improvement
might not seem like the kind of vehicle
to propel the career of one of the most
incendiary comedians of all time but it
did on a 1995 episode of home
improvement Tim Taylor's tool time
descended as it often did into a
discussion about her marriage can be
tough Tim asked if anyone in the studio
audience had liked him been tricked into
a fight with their significant other two
guys named Dave and Jim could relate and
Tim pulled them up on stage what were
you thinking I was thinking of calling
you yes I what no you were as Dave
Chappelle lit up the screen impressing
ABC executives so much that they
commissioned to show about the duo
called buddies it debuted in 1996 with
some changes including the replacement
of Jim Breuer with Christopher Garson
only a few episodes aired before buddy's
was cancelled but landing a prime-time
network TV show couldn't have hurt
Chappelle's early exposure efforts Emmys
snafu most TV fans probably don't know
that performers have to submit their own
names for consideration for the Emmy
Awards and apparently neither did Tim
Allen home improvement was the actors
first major small screen role and he
didn't know how the Emmys worked at
first when Emmy nominations were
released in the summer of 1992 after
home improvements first season Alan
Watson snubbed for Outstanding Lead
Actor in a Comedy Series he just hadn't
submitted his paperwork after somebody
told him the rules Allen made sure to
get his name onto the ballot the next
year he was eventually nominated that
year but lost out to Ted Danson
from Cheers but Alan just couldn't win
his team forgot to submit his name for
consideration the following year much to
his disappointment no not a word you
wanna hear in this house it's old time
meets game time sick comes uneasy to
turn into video games but a home
improvement was so popular during its
run that a game called power tool
Pursuit debuted in 1994 for the Super
Nintendo the plot of the game is that a
new line of power tools by tool time
sponsor benefit tools have been stolen
right before Tim Taylor is supposed to
invade them on the air Tintin goes on a
quest in search of the tools using other
power tools to defeat enemies like
dinosaurs mummies ghosts and other
creatures which definitely weren't a
part of the average home improvement
episode in keeping with the show which
often touted the dumb might show
off-the-cuff ways that real men should
act the game's manual consisted entirely
of the message real men don't need
instructions with a jtt home improvement
played to a lot of different
demographics adult fans loved Tim
Allen's destructive antics or many tween
girls tuned in for Jonathan Taylor
Thomas of the three young actors playing
the Taylor kids jtt is the one who
became the major teen idol his face
appeared on the cover of all the major
magazines and poster foldouts and he was
the stuff young crushes were made of
despite the overnight fame II earned
from the show though Thomas left the
show in 1998 he told People magazine
I've been going nonstop since I was
eight years old I wanted to go to school
to travel and have a bit of a break he
enrolled at Harvard studying philosophy
in history but he also acted in a couple
of movies that didn't sit well with Alan
who was confused as to why the young
star at left Alan told TV Guide he said
it was about going to school but then he
did some films did he want to do films
did he want to go to school after Alan
confronted Thomas on set their feud
became so bad that the young actor opted
not to return for the series finale
Thomas and Alan must have patched things
up at some point since then however
because Thomas guested on four episodes
of Alan's sitcom a Last Man Standing and
his appearances even included some
cheeky references to their history
you know a lot of times that middle
child ends up being the funny one
because he wants the attention and you
look familiar the season that never was
home-improvement wrapped up after eight
successful seasons in 1999 and it was a
decision made by the cast and crew
rather than ABC while he grew
sentimental and upset as a finale neared
Allen also regretted not ending the show
a year earlier when the show was still a
top 5 ratings hit in its final season
home improvement fell to 11th place and
Nielsen ratings but ABC wanted to go
even longer the network even reportedly
offered Allen as much as 50 million
dollars and patricia richardson 25
million dollars to return for one more
season somehow though Allen and
Richardson managed to leave that money
on the table and the world's time with
the tall man was done thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love tea
[Music]